entsprechend von fluch und Segen von
politischer Kommunikation wenn man es
mal sich im Detail anschaut wenn man sie
haben ja das Thema gasumlage schon
angesprochen ein politischer Zombie so
müssen man eher in diesen Tagen nennen
eigentlich Tritte am Wochenende in Kraft
oder diese gasumlage dann in Kraft aber
alle bemühen sich noch verzweifelt in
diesem eigentlich schon totgesagten
Instrument dann auf eine andere Art und
Weise noch mal Leben einzuhauchen indem
man das einerseits abschafft und auf der
anderen Seite für eine Alternative sucht
es gibt eine anderes Beispiel für
schwierige möchte ich es mal vorsichtig
formulieren politische Kommunikationen
das ist ein Interview dass der
cdu-partei und Fraktionsvorsitzende
einem kleinen Sender gegeben hat einem
Ableger einer Zeitung mit sehr großen
Buchstaben und in dem er von
sozialtourismus gesprochen hat im
Zusammenhang mit Flüchtlingen aus der
Ukraine die nach Deutschland gekommen
sind das hat ihm sehr heftige Kritik
eingetragen auch aus den eigenen Reihen
und dann hört er sich heute Vormittag im
Laufe des Vormittag dafür entschuldigt
und falls es Missverständnisse gegeben
habe dafür wie gesagt um Entschuldigung
gebeten aber das ist auch so ein
Beispiel dass man im Moment ein bisschen
vorsichtig sein muss auf dem politischen
Parkett mit dem was man so sagt auch
wenn es möglicherweise was ja nicht ganz
auszuschließen ist im letzteren Fall
irgendwie geschuldet weil einem
Wahlkampf der zurzeit noch in
Niedersachsen stattfindet also alles
nicht ganz einfach die Probleme sind
riesig groß keiner muss man
wahrscheinlich ehrlich sagen hat die
Patentlösung für die Probleme die im
Moment zu lösen sind insbesondere für
die der Energieversorgung und deshalb
steht die heute hier auch bei den
Fraktionen und bei den Stellungnahmen
der Fraktionsspitzen immer wieder im
Mittelpunkt dass man versuchen will oder
auch fordert nach neuen Lösungen zu
suchen um die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
dieses Landes möglichst wenig zu
belasten die SPD wird hier gleich den
Anfang machen wir warten auf Rolf Mütze
nicht den Vorsitzenden der SPD-Fraktion
dessen Fraktion wird sich
zusammenschalten heute bei der Sitzung
mit dem Bundeskanzler so heißt es er
wird über die bisherigen verabschiedeten
entlassungspakete sprechen sicherlich
auch über das Thema
Energieversorgung die gaspreisbremse
oder der Gaspreise Deckel wir ja
gelegentlich genannt wird da sitzen auch
in verschiedenen Häusern noch
verschiedene Experten dran um das zu
lösen also alles im Fluss und alles im
Schwang die Lösung der Wärme und
Gaskrise sollte ja auch besprechen
werden unter anderem auf der
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz das kann
sie auch weiterhin denn diese
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz wird ja
tatsächlich stattfinden was nicht
stattfinden wird ist der Austausch mit
dem Bundeskanzler der im Anschluss fest
vorgesehen war diese Veranstaltung ist
verschoben worden auf den vierten
oktober bis dahin muss allerdings eine
Lösung da sein und jetzt schauen wir
noch mal vorsichtig rüber ob sich vor
dem
spd-fraktionsaal schon ein klein wenig
tut das scheint nicht so der Fall zu
sein dass der Vorsitzende noch nicht da
ist ergibt es ja auch innerhalb der SPD
durchaus Diskussionen und interessante
Anmerkungen gegeben am Wochenende diese
Bars immerhin Bundestagspräsidentin hat
sich geäußert zum Thema Verstaatlichung
von Unternehmen die für die
Energieversorgung oder auch für die
Wasserversorgung da sind es können nicht
sein so zitiere ich jetzt mal etwas
verkürzt dass immer nur Schulden oder
Kosten verstaatlicht würden bzw vom
Staat übernommen und die Gewinne dann
wiederum von den Privatunternehmen dann
eingestrichen und vor diesem Hintergrund
hat sie auch nicht ausgeschlossen dass
beispielsweise Juniper auch wenn alles
wieder in Fluss gekommen ist oder in
Gang gekommen und die und das Gas wieder
vielleicht auch zu deutlich oder
immerhin günstigeren Preisen dann wieder
fließt das Juniper dann trotzdem
innenstaatlich in Händen bleiben soll
und wie gesagt andere Unternehmen aus
dieser versorgungsbranche dann
möglicherweise auch eine Diskussion die
in Gang kommt und jetzt ist Rolf Mütze
nicht da und wir geben rüber auf die
andere Seite der Fraktionsebene
Damen und Herren herzlich willkommen auf
der
Fraktionsebene in der Vorbereitung zur
Plenarwoche wir werden gleich in der
Fraktionssitzung nicht in Präsenz mit
dem Bundeskanzler reden können nicht nur
über seine Reise die an den arabischen
Golf getätigt hat sondern insbesondere
über auch andere politisch wichtige
Themen sondern er wird uns zumindest
dass mein jetziger Kenntnisstand auch
digital für eine kurze Zeit zugeschaltet
sein in der Tat ist diese Woche im
Plenum insbesondere darauf konzentriert
nochmal über bestimmte Entlastungen für
die Bundesbürger in zweiter und dritter
Lesung zu beraten aber was ich genauso
wichtig finde ist dass wir das
Kurzarbeitergeld wenn es dann
erforderlich ist auch verlängern wollen
und das ist finde ich auf
Herausforderung vor dem Hintergrund der
Energiekrise und letztlich eben auch der
Preise die in der Industrie mittlerweile
eine so große Last möglicherweise
bedeuten ein wichtiges Signal an die
Arbeitnehmerinnen und Arbeitnehmer dass
wir sie in einer wirtschaftliche
herausfordernden Zeit durch das
Instrument der Kurzarbeit auch
unterstützen wollen zum anderen gehe ich
davon aus dass wir in dieser Woche in
enger Beratung zwischen den
Koalitionspartnern und innerhalb der
Bundesregierung zu einer
Gesamtabwägung verschiedener Instrumente
die erforderlich sind um die Sorgen der
BundesbürgerInnen und Bundesbürger so
gut wie möglich zu beantworten sie
wissen dass wir bereits beschlossen
haben einen stromdeckel einzuziehen der
dann bedeutet dass wir eben für ein
gewisses Kontingent die Strom Weise auf
ein Niveau halten und dass wir
gleichzeitig aber auch übergewinne
abschöpfen wollen wir stellen uns vor
dass das für den Wärmemarkt für den
Gasmarkt auch der Fall sein wird und ich
bin sehr froh dass eine Kommission die
in am letzten Wochenende sich das erste
Mal getroffen hat offensichtlich sehr
belastbare Gespräche schon geführt hat
und auch zu einem finde ich glaube ich
wahrscheinlich guten Ergebnis in den
nächsten Wochen finden wird aber das ist
auch weitere Elemente gibt die letztlich
zu dieser
Gesamtabwägung mit dazugehören und
deswegen will ich auch heute hier noch
mal sagen das sind keine Deals die
gegeneinander verhandelt werden sondern
alle die Instrumente die notwendig sind
um auf der einen Seite mehr Energie in
dieser Frage bereitzustellen auf der
anderen Seite Verbraucherinnen und
Verbraucher zu entlasten und andere
Instrumente gehören zu Tricks dann auch
zusammen zum Schluss möchte ich sagen
dass das Ergebnis in Italien aus Sicht
der Sozialdemokratischen Partei
enttäuschend ist insbesondere auch
deswegen enttäuschend weil auch vom
Ausland her einzelne konservative
Politiker ich nenne doch ten Weber ganz
bewusst überhaupt nicht unterlassen
haben das konservative Parteien der
Steigbügelhalter für eine Nähe
faschistische Partei geworden sind umso
wichtiger finde ich dass der bayerische
Ministerpräsident und Parteivorsitzende
der CSU hier klare Worte gefunden hat
und ich hätte mich eigentlich sehr
darüber gefreut wenn das auch der
Vorsitzende der CDU getan hat
konservative konservative Parteien in
Europa aber auch in Deutschland dürfen
nicht mit solchen Parteien in
irgendeiner Form eine Zusammenarbeit
suchen oder ihnen überhaupt den Pfad zu
einem solchen Ergebnis legen uns das ist
mir heute ganz besonders wichtig vielen
dank vielen Dank dann kommen wir zu
ihren Fragen Herr Buchsteiner
ist es Ihr Anspruch dass die gasumlage
gar nicht in Kraft tritt sie ist ja im
Augenblick ab 1 Oktober geltendes Recht
wie soll man damit umgehen dass wir der
erste Punkt der zweite Punkt bei der
Gaspreis Bremse an welche welches
Finanzvolumen ist dazu denken können Sie
da wenigstens mal eine Größenordnung
nennen also in der Tat wie sie sagen
ist das mittlerweile Gesetz die
Fälligkeit ist aber auf den
31.10 festgesetzt worden so dass die
Erhebung zwar dann stattfindet aber die
Fälligkeit dann erst zum 31.10 der Fall
sein würde wir hegen schon seit längerem
und das haben wir ja auch bereits in
Dresden getan wie Sie wissen
einen großen Zweifel an der gasumlage
wir hatten damals auch den
Bundeswirtschaftsminister auch durch die
Initiativen an die Hand gegeben zuerst
über eine staatliche Hilfe oder auch die
über Name dieser Firmen in staatlichen
Besitz zu verhandeln und auf der anderen
Seite hatten wir ja auch noch weitere
Vorschläge gemacht so dass ich glaube
dass das in einem gesamt Zusammenhang
dann auch letztlich stehen wird von
daher sehe ich auf der einen Seite dass
die gasumlage nicht das Mittel der Wahl
ist um diese Krise in irgendeiner Form
für die Verbraucherinnen und Verbraucher
sorgenfreier zu gestalten und auf der
anderen Seite gehen wir davon aus dass
wenn man einen Deckel einzieht da
natürlich auch größere Summen von Seiten
eben des Bundeshaushaltes bereitstellen
muss über die konkrete Ausgestaltung
verhandeln werden diesen Stunden und
Tagen
wenn die Bürger bereits Zahlen ab dem
ersten Oktober sie unheimlich schlechten
Entschuldigung wenn die Bürger ab dem 1
oktober bereits zahlen sollen wir wollen
sie das denen erklären das praktisch das
ja alles verrechnet werden muss es er
steht ein noch größeres Chaos und die
zweite Frage geht in der andere Richtung
Herr Merz und der sozialtourismus der
hat sich inzwischen entschuldigt halten
sie das damit für erledigt das Thema und
sie sprechen darüber dass wir dieses
Chaos in irgendeiner Form angestiftet
haben das haben wir nicht ich sage das
sehr klar das habe ich ja eben auch
schon erklärt für uns war die gasumlage
nicht das Mittel der Wahl was wir in
diesem Zusammenhang angestrebt haben
deswegen ist ja auch der
Wirtschaftsminister wieder sehr
zurückgerudert spätestens auch zu dem
Zeitpunkt als Juniper verstaatlicht
wurde eben aber auch andere Unternehmen
möglicherweise
unter diesen Schirm kommen auf der
anderen Seite ich glaube die
Bundesbürger interessiert mehr nicht
dass wir über einzelne Instrumente
sprechen sondern dass wir das
Gesamtvolumen zusammenführen was nicht
alleine im Bereich von gasumlage
entsteht sondern wir wollen ja auch das
mehr Energie insgesamt zur Verfügung
steht und deswegen glaube ich werden wir
in dieser Woche einen tragbares
Gesamtkonzept vorlegen was auch eine
deutliche Reduktion dann bei dem
Belastungen wenn man Gas verbraucht auch
die Folge haben wird
ich finde das eine solche
Begrifflichkeit überhaupt nicht die
Wirklichkeit widerspiegelt alle die
Menschen die ich hier in Deutschland
getroffen haben die vor dem Krieg aus
der Ukraine meistens sind das Frauen mit
ihren Kindern geflohen sind sind dankbar
über die Aufnahme sie wollen dass Sie
hier in Sicherheit leben und keinen wie
er März gesagt hat bestimmten den ich
überhaupt nicht sehe sozialtourismus
durchführen deswegen ist weder der
Begriff angemessen für diese Realität
und dass er sich dafür eben so weit wie
ich es gesehen habe
gerechtfertigt hat ob es eine direkte
Entschuldigung ist das sollte er
vielleicht selbst noch mal sehen ich
finde der Begriff passt überhaupt nicht
in die Diskussion mit
Rolf Mütze nicht der Vorsitzende der
spd-bundestagsfraktionen zu dem was die
Koalition jetzt vorhat in Sachen
Gaspreisen in Bälde soll was kommen und
bis dahin gilt das was beschlossen
worden ist auch wenn es möglicherweise
erst Ende des Monats erhoben wird wir
haben am Anfang gesprochen über
politische Kommunikation Fluch und Segen
politischer Kommunikation auf diese
Richtung hat sich irgendwie oder in
diese Richtung hat sich auch Dietmar
batsch geäußert der Vorsitzende der
Linksfraktion hat nämlich von einer
chaos-ampel gesprochen unter anderem von
einer chaosampel Dietmar Bartsch
heute vor fast einem Jahr war
Bundestagswahl wir haben inzwischen ein
Viertel der Wahlperiode hinter uns
gebracht jeder weiß jetzt kommen noch
zwei Viertel wo Politik gemacht wird und
dann geht es schon wieder Richtung
Wahlkampf ich habe damals nach
Zustandekommen des Koalitionsvertrages
gesagt die muss man differenziert sehen
gesellschaftspolitisch durchaus
Fortschritte vereinbart aber ich will
jetzt deutlich konstatieren von der
Ampel als sich ja selbst so nennende
fortschrittkoalition ist wirklich wenig
geblieben wir sehen aktuell vor allen
Dingen eine chaosampel es gibt einen
kommunikationsdebakel nach dem anderen
und es ist zweifellos so dass der Krieg
der furchtbare Krieg Putins in der
Ukraine die corona-pandemie die
Klimakrise die Inflation die schreiende
soziale Ungerechtigkeit das sind alles
Dinge die zusammenkommen eine
vielfache Krisensituation aber eines
bleibt natürlich in dieser Situation ist
gerade
regieren aus einem Guss erforderlich und
nicht das was die Ampel derzeit bietet
ich will heute hier bei meinem
pressestätten nämlich vor allen Dingen
mit der Energiepolitik der Koalition
beschäftigen das ist das Thema was
aktuell das Land bewegt neben dem großen
Thema der Inflation Robert Habeck hat
heute festgestellt dass die Hütte brennt
und die Zukunftsfähigkeit der Wirtschaft
gefährdet ist ja das ist so und ja hat
auch recht dass viele der Probleme erst
kommen werden aber ich sage auch Robert
Habeck agiert im Moment nicht als
Feuerlöscher es ist leider so dass er
mit vielen seiner Aktivitäten als
Brandbeschleuniger agiert die hohen
Preise die waren lange Zeit Teil der
Strategie aus dem Wirtschaftsministerium
um Sparsamkeit zu erzwingen die Preise
werden die Menschen und auch die
Unternehmen demnächst in voller Wucht
treffen es wird Existenzen vernichten es
besteht eine große Ansteckungsgefahr für
die gesamte Industrie und das kann
Kettenreaktionen auslösen und ehrlich
gesagt man braucht keine
Spitzenforscher oder besonders tolle
Ideen um einen Gegenmittel gegen diese
Energiepreis Explosion zu finden dass
Medikament das hängt längst im
Medizinschrank wir können in viele
andere Länder schauen ein preisdeckel
auf Energie ein gaspreisstreckle ein
Stromkreis Deckel mit Kontingenten das
alles wird in anderen Ländern
praktiziert das ist in Europa in vielen
Ländern Realität aber Robert Habeck ist
hier offensichtlich in eine andere Welt
abgetaucht als er die gasumlage erfunden
hat die die Preise auf gar keinen Fall
senkt das war von vornherein klar
man muss darauf hinweisen dass diese
gasumlage offiziell am 1 oktober also
sprich glaube ich Sonnabend in Kraft
tritt und ist einigermaßen absurd und
ich sage ganz klar diese gasumlage darf
nicht kommen und diese gasumlage kann
ich kommen sie ist ja wie Lars Klingbeil
sagt wie Christian Linder sagt dies das
Gegenteil von wirtschaftlicher Vernunft
deswegen meine Forderung ganz klar Olaf
Scholz muss die gasumlage mit seiner
Richtlinienkompetenz abräumen ich würde
gerne zu Herrn März Fragen und dessen
Äußerungen zum Thema
sozialtourismus und das zurückrudern wie
bewerten Sie diese Aussagen
also das zurückrudern bewerte ich
positiv ich finde diese Aussagen
unsäglich gerade im März der sehr früh
die Ukraine gefahren ist und sich dort
auch hat fotografieren lassen und jetzt
von sozial Tourismus zu sprechen ist
wirklich völlig unangemessen wir alle
kennen die Situation in der Ukraine der
furchtbare Krieg den Putin zu
verantworten hat und da gibt es in
Deutschland Gott sei Dank eine andere
Haltung eine große Aufnahmebereitschaft
vieler Menschen die auch ganz privat
vieles tun und da ist diese Äußerung aus
meiner Sicht unsäglich und ich finde gut
und richtig dass Friedrich Merz das
zurückgenommen hat und sich entschuldigt
hat
Vorsitzende der Ko-Vorsitzende der
Linksfraktion auch noch mal zu
Äußerungen von Friedrich Merz der im
Zusammenhang mit ukrainischen
Flüchtlingen von sozialtourismus
gesprochen hat sich zwischenzeitlich
dafür entschuldigt hat und von einem
Missverständnis geredet hat bzw betont
hat er habe eigentlich die Registrierung
ukrainischer Flüchtlinge hier in
Deutschland gemeint was ihm nicht jetzt
so ganz alle abnehmen wir warten auch
für den Vorsitzenden der Unionsfraktion
der um diese Zeit sein lifestatement
geben wollte zusammen mit Alexander
Dobrindt dem ersten stellvertretenden
Vorsitzenden der Unionsfraktion und
Vorsitzenden der Landesgruppe das
scheint sich minimal zu verzögern das
geht mir aber Gelegenheit Ihnen das zu
erzählen was sie sowieso irgendwann im
Laufe dieser schalte loswerden wollte
nämlich einen Überblick zu geben über
das was im Plenum in dieser Woche im
Bundestag passiert beispielsweise morgen
um 13 Uhr die Befragung der
Bundesregierung die wird stattfinden mit
der Bundesfamilienministerin mit Lisa
Paus anschließend wird es gehen um der
CO2-Preise für Kohle und
abfallversorgung und außerdem ist
beantragt eine Aktuelle Stunde zum Thema
Iran auch zum Fall um die
inhaft gestorbene Iranerin Marsa Amini
und deswegen wie gesagt wird es am
Morgen dann wahrscheinlich auch noch mal
ein paar Verschiebungen geben am
Donnerstag dann ein sehr langer erster
Tagesordnungspunkt eben Deutschen
Bundestag nämlich eine sogenannte
vereinbarte Debatte das heißt es wird
weder Gesetzentwürfe noch Anträge geben
sondern man mit relativ frei diskutieren
über das Thema deutsche beziehungsweise
nationale Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie
bekanntermaßen umfasst das sehr viel
mehr Punkte als nur Umwelt Klima und
Naturschutz sondern auch soziale
Teilhabe spielt eine große Rolle Bildung
und Forschung spielt eine große Rolle
und eine ganze Reihe von weiteren Themen
mehr also ein großes Thema und in diesen
Zeiten auch durchaus wichtiges Thema für
dass sich der Bundestag drei Stunden
Zeit genommen hat anschließend wird über
einen Antrag unter anderem über einen
Antrag der koalitionsfraktion diskutiert
über Handlungsspielräume zur Rettung von
Kindern vor sexuellen Missbrauch die AFD
hat einen Antrag gestellt zu
rückforderungslücken nach
cum-ex-geschäften die sollen geschlossen
werden und das Kurzarbeitergeld bzw die
Verlängerung dieser Regel zum
Kurzarbeitergeld die soll auch noch mal
besprochen werden unter anderem am
Donnerstag im Bundestag Freitag geht es
dann um die Umsatzsteuer auf
Gaslieferungen und
gaspreisanpassung und außerdem um das
Wirtschafts- und Handelsabkommen mit
Kanada ceta das ja viele Monate sehr
intensiv diskutiert worden ist noch zu
Zeiten der großen Koalition und zu
Zeiten also Sigmar Gabriel noch
Vorsitzender der SPD bei der seine liebe
Not hatte seine Sozialdemokratinnen und
Sozialdemokraten jedenfalls Teile davon
von diesem Abkommen zu überzeugen ich
werfe einen kurzen Blick zur Seite es
scheinen weder Friedrich Merz noch
Alexander Dobrindt in sich zu sein die
Frage ist wie wir an dieser Stelle
weitermachen
wollen ob wir beispielsweise erstmal
schauen was Christian dürr der
Vorsitzende der FDP-Fraktion hier vor
einer knappen Stunde gesagt hat und
hoffen dass wir Friedrich Merz und
Alexander Dobrindt dann trotzdem noch
zeitlich erwischen kurzer Blick kurze
Frage ziehen wir Christian Dühr vor
und die Antwort ist ja und deswegen
kriegen sie jetzt Christian Dörr der
sich unter anderem bezogen hat zunächst
auf die Lage im Iran
der erste Blick richtet sich von meiner
Seite in den Iran seitdem Tod von Marsa
Amini sehen wir Bilder von mutigen
starken Frauen die für Freiheit und eine
liberale Gesellschaft auf die Straße
gehen das ist anders glaube ich als im
Iran im Vergleich zu den bisherigen
Demonstrationen und Streiks das geht
weit darüber hinaus die Gewalt gegen
Demonstranten durch das Regime in
Teheran ist aus meiner Sicht absolut
inakzeptabel diese Frauen und alle die
gemeinsam mit Ihnen auf die Straße gehen
verdienen unsere volle Solidarität und
Unterstützung sie wissen das für die
Freien Demokraten eine werteorientierte
Außenpolitik von besonderer Bedeutung
ist und deswegen werden wir in dieser
Sitzungswoche des Deutschen Bundestages
dazu auch eine Aktuelle Stunde haben der
Tod von Masa armini ist Anlass genug und
die mutigen Demonstranten in Teheran
sollten wir gerade durch eine solche
aktuelle Stunde auch als Zeichen des
Deutschen Bundestages unterstützen
ich komme nach Europa in Italien hat es
Parlamentswahlen gegeben Italien das
wissen sie ist eine unserer wichtigsten
europäischen Partner innerhalb der EU
aber auch einer unserer wichtigsten
Handelspartner es ist immer schwierig
Wahlergebnisse in anderen Ländern zu
kommentieren aber es ist davon
auszugehen dass dieser Rechtsruck die
Entscheidungsfindung jedenfalls
innerhalb der Europäischen Union
sicherlich nicht vereinfachen wird
wichtig ist großes Skepsis haben wir
aber eine neue Regierung sollten wir an
ihren Taten messen und nicht an der
Wahlkampf Rhetorik insofern ist es
wichtig dass gerade Deutschland als
stabiler Faktor innerhalb der
Europäischen Union weiter wirkt jetzt
komme ich zur deutschen Politik und zu
dem Thema was sicherlich viele Menschen
in diesen Tagen viele Unternehmen in
Deutschland bewegt nämlich zur
Energieversorgung die Lage an den
Energiemärkten in Deutschland in Europa
ist weiterhin dramatisch eine vor
20-fachung des eine Vervierfachung des
Gaspreises ist für kein Unternehmen und
finde auch nicht für die privaten
Haushalte tragbar und deswegen machen
sich die Menschen zu Recht Sorgen um
diese hohen Preise und Ärzte
Abschlagsrechnung sind ja bereits
zugestellt machen sich zu Recht Sorgen
um diese hohen Preise und die Belastung
die auf sie zukommt deswegen ist es
wichtig dass wir jetzt hier schnell
Klarheit schaffen und das Tempo anziehen
ich erwarte da auch vom
Bundeswirtschaftsminister das will ich
sagen ein Konzept insbesondere für den
Strommarkt nämlich eine strompreisbremse
die ja bereits im Koalitionsausschuss
vor einigen Wochen besprochen und auch
politisch beschlossen worden ist hier
geht es insbesondere um Geschwindigkeit
dass wir schnell zu einer
strompreisbremse kommen damit auf der
Seite jedenfalls Klarheit herrscht und
ist zu Entlastung kommt gleichzeitig
reden wir in diesen Tagen auch über
Maßnahmen am Gasmarkt in Deutschland wir
haben in den letzten Wochen viel über
die prekär Frage auf dem Energiemarkt ja
gesprochen der Bundeswirtschaftsminister
hat den Vorschlag einer sogenannten
gasumlage gemacht und wir sehen jetzt
dass er und auch seine Partei ja große
Zweifel an dieser gasumlage haben es ist
viel diskutiert worden über
verfassungsrechtlich und
finanzverfassungsrechtliche Bedenken die
sind meine Ansicht nach nicht der Grund
sondern es gibt jetzt offensichtlich
Schwierigkeiten eine solche gasumlage
sinnvoll jedenfalls in Deutschland
umzusetzen ich sage aber auch in aller
Klarheit Nichtstun ist keine Option denn
die Preise die müssen runter und
deswegen hat der Bundesfinanzminister
entschieden ein Arbeitsstab in seinem
Hause einzurichten der eine
gaspreisbremse für den Gasmarkt
erarbeiten soll wichtig ist jetzt dass
wir den Gasmarkt stabilisieren die
versorgensicherheit einerseits muss
gewährleistet sein es ist gut dass die
Speicher dafür für Deutschland gefüllt
sind aber gleichzeitig muss eben auch
der Preis runter und hier braucht es
deutliche Signale ich will in aller
Aufenthalt sagen für liberale ist es
nicht leicht ordnungspolitisch nicht
leicht über Preis Bremsen an Märkten zu
reden aber wenn es notwendig ist dann
muss man eben auch in Märkte Eingreifen
das gilt für den Strommarkt wo die
strompreisbremse innerhalb der Koalition
ja bereits beschlossen und besprochen
haben die muss jetzt umgesetzt werden
zügig aber das gilt genauso für den
Gasmarkt wo eine gaspreisbremse dazu
beitragen kann dass die Preise nach
unten gehen Frage zur Aussage von Herrn
Merz Stichwort so sehr
tourismuskolleginnen aus ihrer Partei
haben sie schon geäußert was sagen sie
dazu ist es nicht eigentlich aussagen im
AFD fast schon npd-stil also ich habe
Herrn März dort offen gestanden nicht
verstanden und will in aller Kleid sagen
diese Aussagen von Herr Merz waren
absolut deplatziert sind Menschen die
vor Krieg und möglicherweise Tod
geflüchtet sind aus der Ukraine Schutz
in Deutschland gesucht haben und das in
diesen Tagen wo wir auch eine dynamische
Kriegssituation der Ukraine haben das in
diesen Tagen diese Menschen übrigens
auch durchaus unter Lebensgefahr zurück
in die Heimat gehen um beispielsweise
ihren Ehemann oder Vater wiederzusehen
um dann zurück nach Deutschland
Sicherheit zu kommen dafür habe ich
größtes menschliches Verständnis das als
sozialtourismus zu titulieren ist
absolut deplatziert
Christian Dörr der Vorsitzende der
FDP-Bundestagsfraktion mit Anmerkungen
zum Interview von Friedrich Merz und
Friedrich Merz und Alexander Dobrindt
haben inzwischen auch ihre Pulte
erreicht und vor wenigen Augenblicken
mit ihrem Statement begonnen willkommen
zum pressestate mit der
cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion mit Friedrich
Merz und Alexander Dobrindt ja meine
Damen und Herren herzlich willkommen zu
unseren kurzen pressestatements vor der
Fraktionssitzung ich würde gerne heute
mit einer kurzen persönlichen
Erklärung beginnen sie haben das alle
mitbekommen es hat gestern und heute
einige Aufregung um ein Wort gegeben
dass ich im Zusammenhang mit den
zunehmenden Problemen um Flüchtlinge und
Asylbewerber in unserem Land
gegeben hat ich habe dieses Wort
sozialtourismus
verwendet nicht in der Absicht
irgendjemandem da zu nahe zu treten oder
auch
persönlich etwas vorzuwerfen sondern ich
wollte lediglich darauf hinweisen dass
wir zunehmende Probleme haben mit der
Unterbringung und auch mit der Betreuung
von Flüchtlingen und dazu Probleme
bekommen mit einer größer werdenden Zahl
von Asylbewerbern wenn ich jemanden
verletzt habe dann bedauere ich das sehr
ich bleibe allerdings dabei darauf
hinzuweisen dass wir ein Problem haben
und dieses Problem wird nicht kleiner
dieses Problem wird größer es wird vor
allem dadurch größer dass wir zunehmende
Asylbewerber Zahlen haben in diesem Jahr
die Zahl von 200.000 nicht nur erreicht
sondern möglicherweise auch
überschritten wird und darüber müssen
wir reden das ist ein Thema das auch die
Bevölkerung in Deutschland zunehmend
beunruhigt und deswegen sprechen wir
dieses Thema an in diesem Zusammenhang
wird ein Problem sichtbar dass die
Bundesregierung offensichtlich
unterschätzt nämlich das Problem den
Arbeitsmarkt in Deutschland nicht nur
für Fachkräfte zu öffnen sondern auch
für Arbeitskräfte letztendlich auf allen
Ebenen das ist eine Entwicklung die wir
mit Besorgnis sehen die Bundesregierung
will ja ein Einwanderungsrecht schaffen
das letztendlich den Arbeitsmarkt
komplett öffnet für jede Form
Beschäftigten ich will darauf hinweisen
dass Deutschland seit langer Jahren seit
langen Jahren bereits ein
Einwanderungsland ist Deutschland ist
sogar nach den USA ein Land mit der
höchsten Einwanderungsquote fast aller
westlichen Industrienationen wenn wir
über die Einwanderung in den
Arbeitsmarkt sprechen und dazu sind wir
selbstverständlich bereit dies weiter zu
tun dann geht es um Fachkräfte in den
Arbeitsmarkt und wenn wir einen Mangel
an Fachkräften haben und den haben wir
dann sind wir natürlich bereit auch über
die Bedingungen zu sprechen wie man
Fachkräfte in den deutschen Arbeitsmarkt
stärker einwandern lassen kann wir sind
allerdings dezidiert der Auffassung dass
wir dies nicht als Arbeitskräfte
Einwanderung verstehen sollten
insbesondere nicht als Einwanderung
letztendlich aus allen Ländern der Welt
die gerne zu uns kommen würden um in
Deutschland in den Arbeitsmarkt
einzutreten wir sehen hier große
Probleme auf uns zukommen die wir im
Vorfeld ansprechen wollen und müssen und
wenn die Bundes diesen Weg geht dann
werden die Probleme nicht kleiner dann
werden sie größer wir bedauern dass der
Bundeskanzler die
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz von morgen
abgesagt hat ja er hat Corona wir hören
dass es milde Symptome bei ihm gibt wir
wünschen ihm schnelle und gute Genesung
sind allerdings der Auffassung dass in
der angespannten Situation in der unser
Land ist auch eine
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz virtuell
möglich gewesen wäre und wir haben ja
auch einen Vizekanzler der gleichzeitig
Wirtschaftsminister und Energieminister
ist vielleicht hätte auch der ein
Interesse daran haben sollen dass diese
Ministerpräsidentenkonferenz morgen
stattfindet denn wir können nicht länger
auf Lösungen warten wir sehen
stattdessen einen fortgesetzten Streit
in der Bundesregierung insbesondere
zwischen dem Bundesfinanzminister und
dem Bundeswirtschaftsminister dieses
Land braucht Lösungen und nicht
fortgesetzten Streit in der
Bundesregierung und es wäre in Situation
richtig und notwendig dass der
Bundeskanzler einmal erklärt wie er
eigentlich die Lage sieht und welche
Lösungen er vorschlägt um insbesondere
die Energieerzeugung zu sichern die
Energieversorgung aufrecht zu erhalten
und den Unternehmen wie den privaten
Haushalten eine Perspektive zu geben für
die nächsten Wochen und Monate das ist
das worauf die privaten Haushalte und
die Unternehmen am allermeisten warten
sie brauchen Klarheit es kann ja auch
schwierige Botschaften geben aber sie
brauchen vor allem Klarheit von der
Bundesregierung die Sie in diesen Tagen
leider nicht bekommen die Probleme
nehmen zu Entschuldigung die Probleme
nehmen zu das haben wir mehrfach auch im
Deutschen Bundestag diskutiert unsere
Vorschläge dazu liegen auf dem Tisch
insbesondere ist unsere Position
unverändert was den Krieg in der Ukraine
betrifft wir werden nun nachdem es
letzte Woche wegen der Mehrheit der
koalitionsfraktion nicht möglich war in
dieser Woche eine Abstimmung über
weitere Waffenlieferungen in die Ukraine
am Donnerstag im Plenum haben wir werden
dazu einen namentliche Abstimmung
beantragen und bleiben bei unserem
Vorschlag die ukrainische Armee auch mit
schweren Waffen auch mit Kampfpanzern
auszurüsten ich will für mich persönlich
hinzufügen ich habe große Sympathie für
den
Friedrich Merz vor Friedrich merzweiler
Sitzung seiner Fraktion und der hat sein
Statement wieder relativ lang gezogen
sodass wir Alexander Dobrindt jetzt
nicht mehr unterbringen in dieser
Zusammenfassung und da wir am Anfang
über politische Kommunikation gesprochen
haben hierzu kann man glaube ich sagen
angriff ist die beste Verteidigung das
war Friedrich Merz wir machen weiter mit
Bündnis 90 die Grünen und mit dem
Statement von Britta Hasselmann
alle in der Koalition mühen sich darum
dass die Gaspreise und die Energiekosten
insgesamt sinken dass die Belastung für
die Bürgerinnen und Bürger geringer
werden das ist unser Ziel denn wir alle
haben im Blick dass die Frage der
Entwicklung der Energiekosten und der
Lebensmittelpreise die Menschen
verunsichert und viele Angst vor Abstieg
oder Armut haben deshalb bemüht sich der
Bundeswirtschaftsminister und sein
Ministerium Robert Habeck
ständig darum dass wir zum einen beim
Befüllen der Gasspeicher und zum anderen
übereinsparmaßnahmen die Situation
entzerren so ist es unter anderem
wichtig dass wir uns auch bei dem
energiesicherungsgesetz 3.0 jetzt erneut
darum
Ring und etwas vorlegen werden was die
Frage des Ausbaus der erneuerbaren und
die Nutzung der erneuerbaren Energien
noch mal erheblich steigern wird der
biogasdeckel wird wegfallen es wird
Möglichkeiten für Solar und PV-Anlagen
geben und das ist ein wichtiges Signal
in diesem Zusammenhang ist natürlich
auch die Debatte um die gasumlage die
ein Instrument bisher war um ein oder
mehrere Unternehmen zu stützen als
notwendig gesehen wurde wo jetzt die
Bedingungen sich verändert haben und wir
deshalb auch reagieren müssen in dieser
Situation
wo wir über die Verstaatlichung von
Unternehmen reden ich glaube dass der
gaspreisdeckel an dieser Stelle für die
Gaspreise linkes und richtiges Signal
wäre hier geht es jetzt darum dass wir
in diesem Zusammenhang konzeptionell und
inhaltlich sehr schnell zu einem
Vorschlag kommen die Verstaatlichung von
uniper ist angekündigt das heißt es wird
Veränderungen und Neukonzeption im
Hinblick auf die gasumlage zu erwarten
sein das erfordert dass wir Finanzmittel
in die Hand nehmen auch darüber kann man
nicht hinwegsehen sondern das wird nötig
notwendig sein denn wir können
keinesfalls in die Krise hineinsparen
und wir können keinesfalls mit den
bisher
vorgesehenen Finanzrahmen oder den
Möglichkeiten etwa das Klima und
transformationsfonds denn die mittels
sind hier klar gebunden für
Investitionen in der erneuerbare in
Klima und den Transformation arbeiten
das heißt es wird also notwendig sein
dass wir in der Ampel Übereinkommen und
jetzt auch der Finanz Minister gefordert
Wege und Möglichkeiten aufzuzeigen wie
wir an diesem Ziel der Senkung der
Energiekosten der Einführung eines
gaspreisdeckels arbeiten weiter
vorankommen ein zweites Thema was in
dieser Woche uns alle beschäftigen wird
ist die
ministerpräsident:innenkonferenz die
sich mit dem dritten Entlastungspaket
beschäftigen wird Bund und Länder sind
in dieser Situation gefordert gemeinsam
für die Bürgerinnen und Bürger
spürbar und zielgenau Entlastung auf den
Weg zu bringen dass es unser gemeinsames
Ziel wir haben als Koalitionsausschuss
in der Ampel Vorschläge für ein drittes
Entlastungspaket gemacht im Umfang von
65 Milliarden Euro mit sehr
verschiedenen Maßnahmen von der Frage
der Einführung des Bürgergeldes der
Wertschätzung eines Nahverkehrstickets
der Frage eines von Stromsperren und
anderer Unterstützungsmaßnahmen im
Hinblick auf die
Energiepreisentwicklung die sehr sehr
relevant sind wie etwa das Wohngeld und
der Heizkostenzuschuss jetzt ist es an
uns gemeinsam mit den Ländern sehr
schnell über ein Entlastungspaket zu
einer Klärung zu kommen was dann im
Bundestag in Gesetzgebungsverfahren und
im Bundesrat eine Mehrheit finden kann
und ich finde hier dass Signal und die
Diskussion einiger Bundesländer im
Hinblick auf die Frage wie kann in einer
solchen notlagensituation investiert
werden also die Diskussion die in
Hamburg in Niedersachsen und auch in
Bayern geführt wird über die Frage
welche Wege und Möglichkeiten schaffen
wir im Rahmen der Schuldenbremse
auch investieren zu können sehr richtig
und wichtig das wird sicher etwas sein
was auch bei der Ministerpräsidentin
Konferenz in den nächsten Tagen
gemeinsam mit konkreten Maßnahmen dann
diskutiert werden wird ein dritter Blick
geht auf Europa und geht auf das
Wahlergebnis in Italien es besorgt mich
sehr dieses sehr
nationale Signal in Italien der
Rechtsruck der dort stattfindet ist es
kein gutes Zeichen für Europa insgesamt
und ich bin sehr irritiert darüber dass
insbesondere Manfred Weber an der Spitze
der IVP eine solche Unterstützung für
den Berlusconi Flügel geleistet hat aus
meiner Sicht Irrlicht hat hier die
konservative Union durch die Gegend dass
es
heute auch deutlich geworden mit dem
Vorstoß und der Äußerung von Friedrich
Merz im Hinblick auf den sogenannten
sozialtourismus von Menschen die aus der
Ukraine geflüchtet sind ich finde das
anstandslos und schäbig ich habe dafür
null Verständnis und ich finde auch
Erklärungsversuche seinerseits
inzwischen windelweich
Britta Hasselmann
co-fraktionsvorsitzende von Bündnis 90
die Grünen hier im Deutschen Bundestag
am Ende zur Wahl in Italien bzw dann
auch zu den Äußerungen von Friedrich
Merz zu vor der aber auch zu den
Energiekosten die auf Bürgerinnen und
Bürger zukommen und die Frage wie kann
man das ganze Abbremsen dann ist von dem
Gaspreis Deckel von einer Strompreise
Bremse die Rede auf der anderen Seite
wissen wir dass ab 1 oktober in Kraft
tritt die sogenannte gasumlage auch wenn
sie noch nicht zwingend sofort erhoben
wird aber wir sehen und das hört man
auch aus den Statements der anderen
Fraktionsspitzen hier heute heraus man
müht sich um eine Lösung aber man hat
sie definitiv in diesen Tagen noch nicht
und ob man sie wirklich in den nächsten
drei vier Tagen findet das lassen wir
mal dahingestellt im Reigen der
Vertreterinnen und Vertreter der eine
Fraktionsspitzen fehlt uns noch die AFD
und da lohnt ein etwas intensiverer
Blick in diesen Tagen die drei afd-
rechnete waren ja dieser Tage in der
Ukraine unterwegs auch in Russland
wollten unter anderem auch in die
Ostukraine Reisen das hat Befremden und
Distanzierung ausgelöst in der
Parteispitze nichtsdestotrotz verfolgte
die AFD eine besondere Art der
Beobachtung dessen was gerade etwa in
der Ukraine passierte bzw auch was die
Folgen des russischen angriffskriegs in
der Ukraine sind da ist dann
beispielsweise von einem Gaskrieg gegen
Russland die Rede so ist es genannt
worden am Freitag im Bundestag der
Partei und Fraktionsvorsitzende propala
hat noch vor wenigen Wochen gesagt Putin
halte seine Lieferzusagen ein davon all
dem kann nur noch bedingt die Rede sein
wenn überhaupt ein vor diesem
Hintergrund hat gestern ein sogenannter
internationaler Energiegipfel der
Bundestagsfraktion stattgefunden und das
Ergebnis wurde in einer sogenannten
Diskussionsgrundlage für die Fraktion
zusammengefassten da heißt es die
einseitige durch die EU und die
nationalen Regierungen künstlich
geschaffene Verknappung der Energie und
die Ausweitung des Wirt wird durch
Ausweitung des Angebots beendet
insbesondere in dem russische
Lieferungen nicht mehr behindert werden
dieses Zitat verdanken wir die Kollegen
Schmidt aus dem ARD-Hauptstadtstudio der
sich die Mühe gemacht hat sich dieses
Papier komplett anzusehen und
durchzulesen und dann diesen Satz hier
zu zitieren also eine sehr besondere
Herangehensweise und insofern sind wir
durchaus gespannt was Alice Weidel zu
sagen hatte hier vor der Beginn vor dem
Beginn der Fraktionssitzung der AFD
kommen zu unseren kurzstatements vor der
Fraktionssitzung
auch diese Woche wieder Thema im
Bundestag die gasumlage das Aus für die
gasumlage war überfällig die ist ja de
facto nun auch schon geschehen mit
diesem dilettantischen Instrument hätten
die Bürger für die Folgen falscher
Energiepolitik der Ampel gleich auch
doppelt bezahlen müssen für erst für
Hilfen an die
Energieunternehmen aus Steuermitteln
dann mit der Umlage zur Rettung der
faktisch bereits verstaatlichten
Unternehmen nochmals oben drauf
Verstaatlichung ist nicht nur
ordnungspolitisch fragwürdig sie gibt
dem Staat auch einen Hebel um
Rationierungen und Zuteilung leichter
durchsetzen zu können der geplante
gaspreisdeckel ist teuer und bekämpft
nur die Symptome es ist fraglich ob das
fiskalis überhaupt durchzuhalten ist
ohne den Staatshaushalt zu sprengen und
die Inflation auch weiter
anzukurbeln und eine vernünftige Lösung
muss auch hier an der Wurzel das
Problems ansetzen auch das ist ja schon
immer eine Forderung doch der
afd-fraktion auch die Ursachen endlich
zu benennen und auch die Ursachen zu
bekämpfen und als Lösung auch hier in
diesem Fall das Energieangebot muss
endlich wieder ausgeweitet werden um den
Preisdruck auch zu senken deshalb auch
hier unsere Forderung noch einmal die
gescheiterte Energiewende muss gestoppt
werden und man muss sich auch endlich
eingestehen dass diese Energiewende
gescheitert ist gerade auch in Hinblick
dessen dass die CDU natürlich dort eine
absolute Mitverantwortung hat und
deshalb auch den Weiterbetrieb der
Kohlekraftwerke genauso natürlich auch
die Laufzeitverlängerung der
Kernkraftwerke und perspektivisch
natürlich auch Bau neuer Kernkraftwerke
in Deutschland um den Energiebedarf zu
decken die erdgaspipelines nordstream 1
und nordstream 2 müssen auch repariert
und schnellstmöglich im Betrieb genommen
werden und es bleibt auch aufzuklären ob
die plötzlichen Lex an beiden
nordstreamleitungen auf einen Anschlag
zurückzuführen sind der darauf abzielt
die den Betrieb dieser Leitung als
naheliegende Lösung des gasproblems auch
zu verhindern ich denke das ist auch im
Interesse Deutschlands ist genau das
aufzuklären
wie diese Lage dort entstanden ist wer
verantwortlich ist für diesen Anschlag
auf diese beiden
Pipelines vielleicht noch einen Satz zu
dem Scholz gas-deal den er mit den
Vereinigten Arabischen Emiraten
geleistet hat als Zahlenbeispiel er hat
ja dort wertebasiertes emiratisches Gas
als Erfolg verkaufen wollen es sind
137.000 Kubikmeter Gas die dieses Jahr
noch aus dem Vereinigten Arabischen
Emiraten geliefert werden sollen allein
durch Nord Stream wurden täglich 150.000
Kubikmeter Gas geliefert dass man
einfach mal die Relation hat was hier
als Erfolg verkauft wird und bei einem
Bedarf in Deutschland von über 90
Milliarden Kubikmeter Gas ist das in der
Tat kein Erfolg den Herr Scholz sich
hier
angreifen lassen kann bzw wo man hier
wirklich kritisieren muss dass das für
die für den Fortbestand des Mittelstands
Energie sicher auch hier Gas für uns zu
erhalten nicht gewährleistet ist
das vielleicht von meiner Seite ja
vielen Dank
immerhin hat er ein Ölbaum gepflanzt hat
er das ja hat er so Herr Scholz hat ein
Ölbaum gepflanzt damit ist doch allen
geholfen
von meiner Seite zum weiteren leidigen
Thema der ganzen Aufregung um den
Begriff sozial
Tourismus hätte jetzt fast Terrorismus
gesagt aber sozialtourismus von
Friedrich Merz wortwörtlich hat er
gesagt wir erleben mittlerweile ein
sozialtourismus dieser Flüchtlinge nach
Deutschland zurück in die Ukraine nach
Deutschland zurück in die Ukraine Zitat
Ende
Friedrich Merz hat damit ein sehr
wichtiges Thema angesprochen und dieser
sozialtourismus ist ja nichts anderes
als eine direkte Folge der falschen
Politik dieser Bundesregierung und die
Tatsache dass Flüchtlinge aus der
Ukraine
seit März Hartz IV Leistungsempfängern
gleichgestellt sind und das lädt
natürlich da muss man nicht besonders
schlau sein man braucht da kein IQ von
über 100 das ist schon recht wenig
sondern das lädt eben zu Missbrauch ein
das kann man ziemlich logisch sich
herleiten und darum muss
aufgeklärt werden von Seiten der
Bundesregierung wie verbreitet dieses
Phänomen ist und wie groß der Schaden
für den Steuerzahler ist was wir
brauchen sind dringend belastbare Zahlen
für diesen Phänomen Bereich ein eins ist
klar es ist nicht neu denn bereits in
der Vergangenheit gab es immer wieder
Berichte über Syrer Afghanen und
Libanesen und Iraker die angeblichen
ihrer Heimat verfolgt werden und dann
aber auf Heimaturlaub in ihrer Heimat
gefahren sind und nur nach Deutschland
zurückgekommen sind um das Geld hier
einzusammeln und was hier überhaupt gar
nicht geht ist zu versuchen
das Thema dieses wichtige Thema diesen
Schaden für eine deutsche Steuerzahler
auf Kosten der Political Correctness
wieder wegzudrücken und es ist auch sehr
bedauerlich dass er März dann schon
wieder eingeknickt ist nachdem er so ein
bisschen Gegenwind von links und der FDP
bekommen hat also das spricht auch schon
Bände
Alice Weidel und Tino krupaladin ich
Ihnen am Anfang unterschlagen habe mit
ihren Statements vor der heutigen
Fraktionssitzung der AFD und auch das
war noch mal ein Beispiel für politische
Kommunikation Alice Weidel hat das was
Friedrich Merz bzw sein Team getwittert
hat aus dem Interview das Friedrich Merz
gestern gegeben hatte noch einmal für
bare Münze und für wörtlich auch
genommen wo hingegen der erste
parlamentarische Geschäftsführer der
Unionsfraktion Thorsten frei heute dem
Verlauf des Vormittags gesagt habe dafür
gebe es im Moment keine Zahlen keine
Daten die genau diese Situation belegen
und die diesen Begriff folglich dann
auch rechtfertigen würden aber so ist
das im politischen Geschäft war ich die
Unionsfraktion gerade noch mal erwähnt
habe gibt es mir die Gelegenheit
nachzutragen dass die Union heute
turnusgemäß ihren Vorstand wählt das
macht sie immer nach einem Jahr nachdem
nach der ersten Wahl das ganz spannend
vor dem vor dem Hintergrund der
aktuellen Geschehen ja das war es von
der Fraktionsebene hier im Deutschen
Bundestag seit ihnen schon zwischendurch
mal gesagt morgen 13 Uhr Befragungen der
Bundesregierung mit Lisa Pause
Donnerstag 9 Uhr dann die dreistündige
Debatte zur Nachhaltigkeitsstrategie der
deutschen das könnte auch ganz spannend
werden wir sind jedenfalls dann jedes
Mal für Sie dabei und gelegentlich auch
schon mal ein bisschen eher das war es
für den Moment ich gebe zurück aus
Berlin zu Michael sah in Bonn ganz
herzlichen Dank Erhard für diesen
Einblick in die Fraktionsebene und für
diesen Ausblick auch auf die
bundestagssitzungswoche wir schauen auf
ein tja ganz schwieriges Thema im Moment
im Ausland ein Referendum so heißt es
von russischer Seite ein
scheinreferendum so heißt es von
westlicher Seite